hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today
is an eight-time olympic medalist he's
also
the most decorated us
winter olympian in history his name is
apollo ono
he's here today and this is an
incredible conversation about
grit it's about gratitude mindset
mental health and many other subjects
if you enjoy the work that we do here on
the podcast that we work very hard to
provide for you guys every week it would
mean a lot if you hit that subscribe
button
and also hit that little alert bell so
you can be apprised
every time we put out a new video
with that said please enjoy my
conversation with apollo ono
[Music]
good to see you man thanks for doing
this of course i appreciate you
making the trip out here i want to tuck
you for a long time
and when i saw the trailer for the new
documentary weight of gold
i thought this is the opportune moment
to reach out so thanks for making
yourself available
i'm glad you did and thanks for letting
me take a peek at the
dock at premiere we're doing this on
july 29th so it premieres tonight
everybody's going to get to
be able to see it by the time this comes
out and it was
it was really moving for me
you know i certainly wasn't an athlete
of of your caliber or any of the
you know athletes portrayed in the movie
but this is an
important subject that i've talked about
quite a bit
on this podcast which is making that
transition from
being essentially a professional quote
unquote amateur whatever that means
athlete into becoming a civilian and the
mental health implications
of what that's like and when i look at
your career or i look at
somebody like michael phelps or sean
white who's documented in the film as
well
the outsider perspective is that oh
these people
slid pretty graciously into a civilian
career path
and i think that that perception belies
the truth of just how difficult
that is even for somebody like yourself
who's done it very successfully
it's a traumatic process for anybody who
competes as an athlete at the highest
level yeah the
you said that very well i think the
transition that
olympic athletes face is
it's just i don't want to use the word
unique because i believe everyone goes
through the phase at some point in their
life
right so as you dedicate your career
your path your energy your time towards
one specific goal and thing that
really made you feel and give you
confidence
and has external signaling whether
you're making more money or you're
getting a raise or you're progressing
and people are celebrating you
in the olympic world you kind of only
really get celebrated once every four
years
so if you've got a multiple olympic
career
call it two or three or five in some
cases for some of these athletes
you're only told you're really good when
you're at the olympics
and although that you know that you've
got other qualities and attributes about
your personality that could potentially
be transferable across any career paths
i think that you don't really feel it
right you feel like for example in
speed skating we go in circles like for
a living right
i did that for like 15 years you know
literally working on the same things on
a daily basis and it was beautiful and i
chose that path
and then i use this word a lot you know
that
we have called the great divorce happens
right so my first true love
no longer can i you know have this
person in my life
it's there but i've moved on and there's
no more structure and so
olympic athletes there's no subsidiation
you know there's no subsidy from the
government there's no
right there's no you know salary per se
to be a part olympic team and
that's the beauty of the sport because
that's what you do it because you love
it you do it for all the other
you know ancillary reasons aside from
kind of progressing in your career
but there definitely is a very strong
mental
um transitory challenge that that exists
with all athletes
and i only really felt that and noticed
that i was deathly afraid of it i had
heard about it
but i didn't know until many years into
my retirement
from competitive athletic sport yeah
it's it's basically an existential
crisis i mean you characterize it as
this is my
my my love my first love
but it's more than that because there's
the the the identification
with your sport is so um deeply
ingrained and integrated with who you
are that there's no distinction between
the two i mean
michael phelps puts it quite bluntly
when he says you know i i'm michael
phelps a swimmer but i don't know who i
am
right who who am i outside of this sport
who is apollo
outside of speed skating and making that
leap and trying to figure that out
is exacerbated in the olympic context
because of the very fact that it's once
every four years
and that your entire life boils down to
this very specific
moment that happens in a snap and then
it's over
it's not like a professional career
where you know you're
on television once a week or whatever it
is during a season
you go from anonymity to being
everywhere
to suddenly being um
not just anonymous but without any clear
trajectory forward and
as an athlete you know how to set goals
you know how to work towards them you
have this kind of tunnel vision on on
how you approach that and move forward
and your whole life is consumed by that
and then in the wake of that when that's
over there's just blue sky
and there's no coach and there's no
clear
path forward as to what you're supposed
to do
and you're forced to reckon with
yourself for perhaps i think
a lot of athletes for the very first
time yeah it's something that i
when i went through that process i was
deeply
afraid of not finding something that
would drive me in the same way that
sport did that the olympic path did
and i also was deeply afraid of being
that guy who
came up out of retirement to go back
into the competitive world of olympic
sport because i couldn't replace it
i think now i'm at a point in my life is
that why do you think you stayed in it
no 2010. i stayed in it because i really
loved the sport
and i loved what i was doing and i think
i was doing it for all the right reasons
but i was physically
capable to go to another one potentially
two more olympic games
and i felt very actually i felt at the
top of my game at that last olympics and
things were starting to come together it
was making sense
but i was also hungry to kind of
transition out and find what other
facets of my personality i could grow
and that's the unknown that was the kind
of fear poor
part now i was lucky because i was
celebrated by nbc they
should you know they had they had the
spotlight on me when i was racing around
they had showcased the stories i had
sponsors but for every one of me
there's a thousand athletes who you
don't know their name
they've trained just as hard uh as i
have they were alongside of me they were
part of my team
for many many years and we don't we
don't celebrate them that's that's just
the external signaling that is the kind
of
culture that we live in but and so i've
always thought
i was i was you know i've been writing
this book around kind of it's called
hard pivot which is about like how do
you hard pivot from one career
or one path to the next and then at what
point do you decide that you
you can succeed down this other path and
what i found was a lot of the friends
and a lot of the athletes that we were
training with
really suffered in a great deal from the
mental
kind of constraints of they're not good
at anything else and then they'll never
be good anything else and
they'll never find that spark right so
chemically i mean
right that's a whole newcomer nothing
will ever be as exciting as that
how could it be how could you walk into
the opening ceremonies yeah
i mean it's going from the cover of
sports illustrated one week to
you know working at home depot the next
week i mean lolo jones tells that story
of
working at the gym making smoothies when
she's on television like winning in a
track meet and how that just bent the
mind of
you know the person who she was giving
the smoothie to
yeah and there's countless stories like
that i mean there's literally there's
there's so i talked to a friend i won't
say his name but i talked to a friend he
also retired on the same time that i did
had a lot of success in the sport and i
asked him where and how he was doing in
his life and his response was
i'm doing fine you know then i you know
the conversation continues on further in
about an hour in the conversation
i start to feel that this person who
i've known for a very long time
is really missing something and he
started he just breaks down he
essentially just tells me he's like
i have all these kind of external things
in my life that that the americana
culture has told me that is the american
dream
but i deep down am so lost the only
thing holding me together is my family
it's the only reason why i'm getting up
and i'm going to do what i'm doing on a
daily basis and that was really
that was scary to me to hear because i
have seen and experienced
friends who suffer from depression i
competed with them they were part of my
team some of these guys wouldn't leave
their room for 48 hours
and they were just sleeping and i was
like are you sick like what's going on
like he's like oh i just don't feel well
and
you know this is this is like nearly 15
years ago so
we didn't know what some of these guys
were facing there definitely was no
resources associated there were sports
psychologists and we had access to them
but
you know when you live in a sport where
you know you don't want to show any
weakness you don't want to show any
signs and and you're kind of only
rewarded when you can show up and be
strong and tough and resilient and those
things that we strive to be
um you don't associate that
vulnerability i think with you know
reaching out and asking for help
which is tough yeah i mean that's
another powerful point that's made in
the documentary if if you blow your knee
out you're gonna have access to all the
best
orthos and all the people that you need
to rehab that knee and get you back
on track but if you're having a mental
difficulty
a you're not going to admit it because
that's
showing this weakness that you're
trained to avoid doing
and second to that the resources
although
perhaps available it's not the same
thing it's sort of like
oh well you're on your own for that
right it's not understanding the
holistic nature of what it means to
compete
and stay healthy at the highest level i
feel like that's changing though
it's changing it's absolutely changing
and i think there's been much more kind
of
attention focused in and around hey
how is this athlete right how you know
not in terms of physically but how's
this athlete like on a daily basis
how is their sentiment how is their
energy what is that what are they happy
about outside of sport
and the much more focus around creating
some balance associated
uh you know these things didn't exist i
think early on in the kind of olympic
careers and sports and we didn't have
all the other
i think access to information in terms
of social media and
understanding but there's absolutely you
know
the business of the olympics is is
beautiful in one side and on the other
side it's a business
and that business is how do we generate
more olympic medals
for the us and so as long as you're
winning
um we'll give you whatever resources
that you need as soon as you start to
falter
we try to figure out how to bring you
back to top but if you don't if you
don't succeed we got to find the next
person online
and so it's this kind of churn and the
wheel i think some of the athletes and
i've never faced this
rich like in my life i've been very
lucky to not have those kind of
depressive thoughts
um or maybe i was just too scared to
have them so i just started running
and that was my escape but for sure and
for certain i've seen it
and it was devastating for some of these
guys so much so that people are taking
their own lives
you know speedy you know jared peterson
you know we had been to
various summits together i've seen him
you know full of energy
and there's been many athletes who
suffer from that same thing and so
now with i think the world having this
kind of understanding that these these
these global epidemics and pandemics
that are existing
in our society they're going to have
these massive mental repercussions
and people recognize that olympic
athletes although we look at them as
being superhuman
they're just human beings who focus on
one sole task
right i mean this documentary was meant
to come out
in the middle of the olympics right
there's no olympics it's being postponed
a year
and you know i can't help but think
about the mindset of the athlete who's
been training their whole life
for this summer only for it to be
deferred a year and for
you know the lay person they might think
well they just you know it's another
year like just train you know but they
don't understand like
that might be their window they might
not be able to maintain that for another
year or
just the the mental fortitude the
emotional
um strength that's required to
endure the training for another year
after that kind of setback
is i think underappreciated like that
the toll that's being
placed on these athletes right now to
have to wait out
another year and even not even knowing
if that's going to happen
has got to be devastating it's
devastating and i think but athletes
you know on one side the ones who are
younger this is this is a benefit to
them
but they probably need another year
anyway right there's going to be those
people that benefit from this of course
but i guarantee the results are going to
be different what about the person who's
trying to hang on
or like this is their 2010 or whatever
you know this is their third or
you know are they going to be able to do
that and it's it's very challenging
right
someone who's you know and just to put
in context right imagine
you've said your family and you're
you're you know you said hey i need to
focus on this this is what makes me
happy
just live with me for four years this is
the last run
and then at the last minute you say hey
i need another 12 months
now we're talking it's not just like hey
leave me alone we're talking about real
severe financial
kind of commitments associated with
these sports because these athletes
don't make a lot of money most are
probably in debt between 12 and 30 000
a year every single year um just to
pursue this dream yeah and although you
can get subsidized by
the ngbs the ngbs is the national
governing body so usa track and field
usa cycling usa speed skating
but it's pretty meager for the average
olympic hopeful who's maybe a national
team member
yeah so if you go and you are the .001
percent
of your sport and you go and you win a
world championships in short track speed
skating
uh you have a bonus of 12 000 that is
your
that's like your prize money is 12 grand
now you can spend 12 grand on equipment
in a year
easily so i think the financial
repercussions and
you know they are what they are that's
that's amateur sports we're not on
television
consistently we're not x games you know
material we've tried to be
and so you know the the broadcasting and
the media side there's no money for them
to be able to reproduce that yeah
but we as americans love the olympics
and we love what it stands for and we
love cheering for one team
finally right and everyone comes
together and
really the documentary i think what
brett rapkin and everyone has done such
a good job of is bringing the awareness
around
kind of the mental repercussions
associated with what the weight of gold
actually does
yeah um and and there's no one i'm
definitely not one to ever say
hey i'm i'm a victim you know there's no
resources for me
um it is what it is right
and that's my that was how i led my life
but there's many others who
suffered much more than i did and that's
i feel that i have empathy and deep
kind of um you know i i feel grateful
for
them to be able to share their voices
and then people who i consider to be
leaders
in that transition people like jeremy
bloom people like sasha cohen who
have been very open about talking about
their fears and how they've been driven
by their own failures
in sport and how that transfers out um
i mean but even like i'm curious rich
like with you when you were
when you were going through your kind of
your bottom right i mean at some point
your identity
as being you know high-powered knowing
your craft
and then moving into a whole new realm
and changing your life i mean that is
such an extreme
it's such an extreme change like how do
you mean how do you
feel i mean it's you know it's a it's a
very inelegant process
you know i i i experienced a very low
level of what we're talking about when i
retired from swimming i swam at stanford
in the late 1980s and i swam with
olympic gold medalists and world record
holders and and the nc2a champions and
the like
and i was very much a benchwarmer i was
okay i was never great
uh but when i went but i loved it you
were good well i was good but i was not
i was never going to the olympics i was
never that good
um but i remember but i loved it and i
put everything that i had
into the sport and when i made the
decision to retire
i remember having you know i had i had a
bit of an existential crisis about like
what am i going to do i never i didn't
really spend much time thinking about
what else made me happy
so i can only imagine like extrapolating
from that what the experience is like
for somebody who's at the very
you know peak of their powers and i saw
some of my teammates
go through this who are you know much
more
successful than i try to figure out that
transition
so i had some connection with that
process
then i had struggles with drugs and
alcohol and i had to kind of you know
meet my maker with that so i've had
many permutations of reinvention over
the years so by the time it came to
walking away from the law i felt like
i'd already done it a couple times so
perhaps it was a little bit less
traumatic for me then but it's never
easy and i think
in the context of being an olympic
caliber athlete
what's unique is this incredibly
well-honed ability
to focus singularly on a specific thing
that gets you excited
right this this incredible opportunity
that you have in front of you
and when that's gone you still have this
amazing skill set of knowing how to set
a goal and work towards achieving it
but somehow it it feels like
it doesn't it's like jamming a square
peg into a round hole when you try to
apply that
to the real world until you can find
some lane
that gets you just as excited or perhaps
somewhat excited in comparison to what
it's like to be an
athlete chasing that dream yeah i think
somewhat excited is probably
yeah it's never gonna be it's never
gonna be like you know going to
go into the olympics that's okay right
and that and that's okay and i think
that
that took me a long time to come to
terms with
where i felt that i needed to find
something to replace the same
fire and drive and passion and love that
i had but what you did was you started
doing that
while you were still competing i mean
you not only did
dancing with the stars in the middle of
your career you freaking won it
right and that was in like 2007 right
seven yeah so you were still at the
height of your
athletic powers so you were making moves
while you were still an athlete you
weren't living the monk-like
existence that perhaps many of your
peers were
yeah you're absolutely correct and i
think that that experience was
you know aside from being like this
crazy reality show that i had no
experience or really understanding what
i was doing
i just kind of everything to me looked
like a nail i just work as hard as i can
and just put in as much time as i can
and then i can beat everybody else that
was like the kind of very simplistic
mindset
and then when i experienced that on the
show it kind of opened my
my brain up to like oh my gosh there's
people out there who don't watch the
olympics
wow i was like that's weird you know i
was like i lived in this
weird bubble where i just i just assumed
that everyone watched the olympics
and because you know what you're doing
in your life seems to be the most
important thing at the time
right and then it took me a long time
post to really figure out like okay
like what am i good at what do i want to
do what's important to me
do i just want to chase making money do
i want to be successful how do i win at
business how do i become the best at
business in the world
but where did that impulse come from i
think it was just i just this
preconditioned belief that's how i
should be so
i'm like this guy who loves to win
really hates to lose
i'm willing to do whatever i can to
dedicate myself
to be fully immersed so whether it was
chasing dreams in asia i'm learning
about different cultures and businesses
there
falling straight on my face and and
getting involved with businesses i knew
nothing about um
but all that at the time i didn't know i
didn't start having the introspective
conversation with myself
probably like into my 30s and that's you
know i retired at the age of
27 28 years old it wasn't until like my
early 30s and mid 30s where i really
started to ask the question
what does apollo want out of life and
what does life
want for apollo and i think that a lot
of athletes
struggle with that question to even ask
it right
or it does it doesn't get asked until
the the curtain is closed on the
athletic career
right it seems like you had the ability
the facility to start asking that
question
when you were still competing so that
when the retirement
you know came you were already well set
up to be able to
figure out your next moves i think maybe
optically i was well set up
i mean yeah that's what it looks like i
think but inside because i'm i have a
poker face right that's that was the
game for short track speed skatings i'll
never
show you what the real pain that's
happening beneath the first surface
right unless you really know me that was
really going on so this like
internal struggle and conflict was
always
i cannot lose in anything that i'm doing
outside the sport and that's just
life doesn't work that way right right i
mean you're going to lose that's how you
learn
well speed skating there's a lot of
analogs to swimming like you you you're
somebody who
is trying to control the variables all
the time right and as a speed skater
you can control your training your
mindset um
you know how you're how you're prepared
physically and mentally for every single
race
you can't control your competitors and
that's perhaps the biggest
distinction between like swimming you're
not all in the same lane
you know crawling on top of each other
like you are in in short track
uh but there is this sense that if i can
can just
control everything that i'll be able to
get the outcome that i want right and
that doesn't work in life at all
no i mean we are in the driver's seat
right
and we're steering but what's coming at
you you've got no control over it's just
really how you react
and then eventually respond to those
types of kind of circumstances
right you know someone asked me when i
was i think i was 17 or 18 years old
we used to we used to have these things
called the olympic summit and so they'd
bring together
all of the um olympic hopeful and
existing olympic
team members together once every kind of
two or three years and we would go to
like a colorado springs or go to utah
we would talk about all of these things
all these transitory challenges you're
gonna face and it's
right over my head don't even hear it
and someone asked me and i wrote this
down
i think it's still in utah and one of
the universities and they're like what
do you want to do when you retire
i was like i'm retired what are you
talking about
i was built for what i'm doing right
here there's nothing else that exists
after this
there's no space to entertain that
because that's a distraction from the
goal that you're seeing
you're jumping out of the airplane
trying to land on a target and you have
no parachute if you land
you're safe if you don't you're you're
gone and that kind of commitment level
i i thrived on and became addicted to uh
it's probably not the most you know risk
adverse
right um especially in a sport like
short track where you run the same race
four times and probably get four
different winners but
you know there's an addictive quality to
kind of those types of things and we
develop i think these conditional habits
based upon
how we live in that sport whatever it is
i mean to me
swimming was such a you know i was a
swimmer when i was very young
i had dreams of going to stanford when i
was a kid it was cool that you started
as a swimmer
yeah i like that it was it was awesome
my swimming career was cut short quite
fast probably like 13 years old i
stopped swimming
um but i was like i was 12 years old i
was like did you swim for
multnomah or one of those club teams i
swam uh in seattle for highline swim
club uh-huh
um at the time and uh bill christensen
was my was my first coach
great coach uh but i noticed pretty fast
that it wasn't like swimming was
probably not going to be
for me and then my dad was always trying
to push me into all these different kind
of
athletic activities simply because i was
just had so much energy and he didn't
want to get into trouble
so let's take it back you grew up with
your dad single dad
um you've characterized him as a tiger
dad
of sorts right
it's kind of amazing the sacrifices that
he made
to you know try to get you in the right
lane
yeah my dad did he was he's amazing and
you know growing up in a single
household and then having my father
kind of dedicate his life to me
literally could care about nothing else
at a very young age i noticed that my
dad just pushed me and pushed me and
pushed me whether it was trying to push
me in academics whether it was trying to
push me
in sport i mean he placed me in all
these different activities just to
figure out like this kid's got to be
good at something
there's got to be some spark there and
then when he saw this sport of short
track speed skating that's what really
made him
kind of you know push a little bit
forward i originally was like an inline
speed skater which is even
much smaller sport doesn't even exist in
kind of most of these areas of the us
but
in seattle where it rains a lot you kind
of go this indoor track and you
basically
it's like speed skating but on inline
speed skates and my dad used to make me
get up at a very early age
a very very early time and he used to
make me go skate
inside of these church parking lots at
like 3 30 4 30 in the morning
before he had to go to work i remember
you talking to
mike gervais about this yeah he'd wakey
he literally
because there was only the ability for
you to
practice like once a week or something
like that yeah because of track times in
his work schedule
that he decided that you guys were just
going to wake up at 3 30 every day and
go find some parking lot
and he was going to coach you he would
put this like on me
it's like classified as like child abuse
i think pretty much now
that's intense man you know when i think
about like
the mindset that you adopted to be the
champion that you
are i can't i can't help but also think
of you know the impact of of how you
were raised by your dad and
and you know in so many ways so all of
us
you know our behaviors are are get
locked in
you know based upon our experiences as
young people
and and we manifest those traumas
whether macro or micro and
in different ways and as well
intentioned as he was and i'm
certain that it all came from love you
know how much of that
do you reflect back on and think you
know i'm being fueled
with you know by something that perhaps
is not super healthy
as a result of those experiences i think
a lot of that fuel
is unhealthy it can generate a very
healthy kind of you know result
but i think i would argue that most
athletes who
compete not even at the highest level
but who are driven by
some extreme nature have some form of
micro trauma that is there whether they
recognize it or not that is really
driving them
and sport happens to be that outlet and
that catalyst that allows them to
express themselves in a way where
you know you've got these guard rails up
and you've got rage you've got you know
fear failure you've got insecurity all
these elements i think that we all go
through depending on what fuels you
um and you can just kind of ping-pong
your way back and forth to reach the
finish line
and sport was like that for me right and
there was times when i had rage
when i used pure anger for no reason
i have no idea where it's coming from
right um complete fear of failure
and that obsessive ocd just cannot
get this sport out of my head for even a
fraction of a second of a day
it's just everything that i do has to be
controlled like you said it has to be
dialed in um somebody on the other side
of the world is training harder than i
am
who wants it more than me who's more
genetically superior than i am therefore
i have to be better in all these other
elements whether it's nutrition recovery
training mindset meditation
visualization
uh and it's obsessive and it it can be
and became at times
in my career very toxic to the point
where
there was a lot of self-sabotage um and
there's all kinds of things that happen
i think in in the sports world that that
we see and i i feel like when i see some
of these documentaries now on athletes
i'm like when i watch them like i know
exactly what that guy guy's thinking i
know why he's doing what he's doing
i know what he's driven by and i hope
he knows the reason why i hope he
recognizes that
this is the reason why he is what you
know and the way he's reacting but to
his teammates to his family in his own
personal life
because if it's not understood i think
it can be very very
detrimental down the line when you have
to retire so flipping that lens on you
what do you think was the the driver
like when you're this young person
and you're discovering sport and you
show an adeptness at a very early age
where did the impetus come to be so
successful at it or to
you know basically become this champion
like what was behind that
so there was many points in my career
where it slightly changed
um but it was there was times where i
was driven by
i just want to make sure my dad was
happy so when i was much younger i just
want to show him that
that hey like approval from the approval
from dad i think i i still
probably want that today in various
forms right because that's that's
how i've been hardwired and then there's
times where
the psychological pain of losing was so
great
i couldn't sleep and give an example in
the 2006 olympics which was in torino
italy
i had raced the 1000 meters and i had a
dream like several nights before the
final of this race that i had made a
strategic move in
which in this dream i won the race in
the actual final i never
performed on that idea in that dream and
instead
i got third and so while everyone around
me from the sports psychologists to my
existing teammates and coaches were like
yeah that's great like
two games back to back you you're on the
podium again that's amazing
i you know trying to go to sleep that
night looking over at the ice rink
because we had this apartment that
overlooked the ice rink
i couldn't sleep i was tormented it was
like this this nightmare
that i couldn't stop thinking about and
so that obsession i mean i ran the race
the race is already over i ran the race
thousands of times over my head
and kept asking myself why did you not
move why did you hesitate
why did you do this and i became and i
got stuck in this hole
and it was this downward spiral where i
just shut the world out
i couldn't i couldn't communicate with
with anyone
because they didn't see and hear what i
had so that psychological pain was
so it was so deep that
that's why i think i trained so hard
later in my career was like i couldn't
deal with that feeling do you think that
that comes
from a an internal
drive to like this sense that you didn't
live up to your own personal potential
or is it
an external thing where
it's being driven by the performance of
other people like
you you said you hate to lose like so is
it is it about
being the best version of yourself or is
it about beating other people
like internal versus external so it was
never about
for me it was never about beating other
people although that was used the tool
um often right and or being beat maybe
yeah so being beat or when i beat myself
was kind of the
the biggest thing so when i was training
in my sport
i always was probably my greatest asset
and my biggest enemy always well you
talked about
you you mentioned self-sabotage so
explain that
a little bit so like in short track
speed skating you know four to six
people are on the ice at one time
no one has their own lane you're racing
around this um ice hockey rink around
these
these these blocks and 11 meter track
strategy is very important
so in a thousand meter race which is
nine laps around
um time doesn't really matter it's all
about the strategy that raised so you
can win the race and the time can be
very slow it doesn't it just depends on
who's leading and what
you know when people are attacking
during this race and so what i noticed
quite early probably in like the early
2000s like 1999 2000 was that i was so
strong physically because i had been
training so hard
and i was just so dialed in technically
that i started to win
easy very easily and that became not
enough so when i started to win too
easily
i started to kind of delay when i would
attack at the end of the race so if
there's nine lap race i wouldn't attack
till like lap number you know one lap to
go
two laps to go which is very dangerous
because had i just skated towards the
front of the pack
in position one or two versus in being
position five six or seven
i have to pass all those people and all
of those people who i have to pass
is a potential for them falling me
making a mistake the ice being brittle
breaking out one of these things and so
i became addicted to that feeling of
waiting until the last minute and seeing
if i can still thread the needle
every time and then that kind of
gratification
started it was you know i would delay it
delay it delay it delay it and i
remember one time
one of the guys who i really really
looked up to in the sport said to me
after a race that he had just watched me
barely actually qualify for the next
round because i had done that exact
exact same strategy of waiting um this
french canadian guy he's like apollo
you playing with fire man you're gonna
get burned what's interesting about that
is it's a strange brew of out of control
ego like i'm so
good that i can linger in the back and
still pass all of these guys in the last
lap because i'm so much better than
everyone else
and i don't deserve to be in the front
right like i don't feel comfortable
leading the race so i'm gonna hang back
here
and that's a very that's a weird
it's it's weird that those two senses
if i'm getting this right can co-exist
you you the three the first person who's
ever said it
um in that way the reason i noticed it
is because it's it's a
it's a unique thing like i'm in recovery
for a long time and that's a unique
kind of quality of alcoholism where you
feel like
you're better than everyone else and
you're the biggest piece of [ __ ] in the
world
yeah and part of the work is like
confronting that and and working your
way
through that and i dealt with that for
many many many years there's times when
we would
i would just do these workouts these
training workouts um
that just make no sense they don't fit
in the training program
their additional their additional
training sessions they're more
detrimental
than than beneficial and i just wanted
to see how close i could get to cracking
my own
kind of mental ability how hard can i
train
in the most obscene hours of the day
doing the most crazy workout that i
would normally never do when i was fresh
with fresh legs
how do i go climb the manitou incline
right after doing something really
stupid
right how do i go drive there like at
the end of the day at like 9 10 at night
you know bring fl bring flashlights
bring a 45 pound weight vest and do
skating jumps up this thing
i've done the incline that's that's
brutal yeah that was like our training
ground wow
that was like the test in colorado
springs was like doesn't matter how fit
you are it just hurts the same
just you know so you develop this
extraordinary mental fortitude but
essentially you're you're somebody who
when i when i
you know i know a little bit about your
training regimen it it seemed like you
were over trained all the time or
on the verge of things i mean when you
look at
short track you know the the track is so
small i mean
it looks like you're taking about i
don't know six
strides or strokes i don't know what you
call it per se
pushes per side before you take a corner
right right it's so quick i mean you're
a sprinter
essentially even the longer races are
essentially sprints yeah you're an
animal
training the way that you were training
like you were doing an ironman or
something like that
which i know you've done we could talk
about that but yeah you know that i
you know the sprinters that i know from
swimming and from track and field
like they're very careful not to do too
much
they pick their hard moments they're
like cheerfully yeah right they sprint
and they rest
full recovery sprint then rest and i
think there's now we know
i think we kind of didn't really know
back then where
i was really over training and most of
the time
my coaches had to pull the reins back on
me and say hey like
you know like this is not necessary
you're actually digging yourself into a
deeper hole
and i had something in my head that like
a sports physiologist told me when we
were training in lake placid one time
and doing our vo2
and wind gate tests and he said we were
doing them at altitude and they were
doing them again at sea level and he
says
you need to live at altitude because
your body's natural
adaptation phase is very high so you
will benefit
from living in colorado springs from
living in salt lake city utah
at being at 4 600 or 6 300 um your
body's ability to recover
is was extraordinary he had to clear
lactate out of its system
so you need load and you need volume so
he told me that when i was like 15
wow so that was ingrained in my head
that i needed more and i also felt like
i did need more but probably not the
degree that this extreme training but i
wasn't seeking the physiological
benefits i was
i was seeking something i think it was
just testing myself
do you think on some level there was a
self-punishment aspect to that
absolutely yeah and i've heard you talk
about this often
where you know it's like
again there's this addictive quality to
how close can i
get to the end how deep in the hole can
i get
and then still come out and that racing
strategy was something that i battled
with my early coaches for a number of
years and
often it became kind of like the style
of skating that i was known for
and so athletes knew to prepare for that
at some degree yeah what's interesting
about your career also is
early on i mean you clearly showed this
prowess and you have this talent
although perhaps not the most you know
technically dialed in
of the skaters um you had incredible
success at a very young age but
that success tended to be erratic like
you would win and then you would lose
and then you would take time off and you
were kind of all over the map
so a big part of your maturation of an
athlete i suspect had to do with
trying to normalize your success and try
to trying to create
consistency in your approach and the
consistency was is the number one aspect
that i think i was
missing when i was younger because i was
so erratic because my mind was all over
the place
it was like honing in these like
thousands of laser beams into just
one that was concentrated that had a
goal that had a target
and had some guardrails around it and
that's the beauty of like professional
sports teams or olympic teams is you
have this these
these kind of support systems to guide
you along the path right
uh but i was that was you know i i've
had many many instances in my career and
in my life where
i've just gone in the wrong direction
because the guardrails weren't up and i
think now the guardrails are not my team
the ones that i set for myself
so i've learned more about myself to
know
what my tendencies are what my kind of
precondition
habits or what i you know what i go to
as a a reaction versus like taking a
deeper moment and saying like does this
kind of fit into the overall theme and
goal of what i'm trying to do and it's
taken me a long time to come full circle
in that regard
and not just you know saying no to
things
you know is very difficult and pursuing
things that i think are really important
and meaningful i think in life and in
society and
how can i help other people make less of
the mistakes perhaps that i've made in
my life
um and learn from some of these kind of
painful questions
around you know like why i did what i
did during these times and
i mean there's many times in my career
rich when i i kind of just threw i just
i was throwing the dice with my own
life like i was just literally throwing
the dice like i had everything you could
possibly imagine when it came to being
dialed in for the sport i was 14 years
old
i've been training for eight months like
professionally with like a junior
national team
it's just after you moved to asia
so i was invited to go to lake placid
and live and train in this olympic
training center and
eight months later i was number one in
the united states and so that
that like skyrocket to fame like what
does that do to it that's like a child
actor
right right that's not good for your
psychology you have no idea now i'm
living and traveling with grown men who
are double my age
who understand dedication and sacrifice
and goal setting and visualization
this was all just a pure raw talent at
that point
yeah you know it's kind of amazing that
you didn't
i mean you say you you went sideways but
in in in many ways you didn't i mean you
could have you could have
you know pulled a crazy tiger woods move
or a todd marinovich type
situation you know you had a similar
kind of dad situation
it sounds like and then you were in
these very structured environments with
a bunch of people trying to
figure out how to make the most of this
talent that you had
but for the most part it you know you've
had some maybe
slight errant moves in one direction or
the next but for the most part
i feel like you've kept it together
pretty good i yeah
you know i know i mean i i feel like
that and i think that
that's got a lot to say about my dad i
mean make no mistake i've made
tremendous amount of kind of falters and
missteps in my life post career
i i think that i just i look at them
differently now so
they don't affect me in the same way and
by that is i don't dwell on them as much
i believe it's all part of the process i
kind of have a much more open view
around you know how we live as human
beings and how
i used to think that i was this very
special person who
possessed this special gift that no one
else in the world had
i just don't i don't know if i believe
that i believe in myself and i'm
confident myself
i just believe that anyone can do it
they just have to find a way to unlock
that inner potential or that
fire that exists in there that it maybe
has never been touched before
felt and what do you think that is about
like when you look at
sport in general or just success in
general what is the differentiator
between
the the also ran and the gold medalist
like
you know in olympic sports it's it's
nothing you know it's a thousandth of a
second it's a tenth of a second
between the guy who gets the medal and
the person that that that
um goes home without anything what do
you think it was about
your approach that fueled you
to such heights from from like a mindset
perspective
so and i can't speak for all sports
because
you know basketball and football and
soccer these sports are massive and so
there's
way more athletes who are competing in
those realms but in short track speed
skating it was a fairly early
you know kind of a new sport to the
world of the olympics it was introduced
as a
demonstration sport in 1988 and
i i just saw when i first started really
concentrating dedicate my life towards
the sport i saw
that the the other athletes who around
me who were my teammates
i saw that they just followed the
program in a simple way right they just
followed they just did what they were
told
and and which there's nothing wrong with
that the training program was hard it
was difficult it was built by
people who understand sports science and
physiology and i just felt like
how can i beat them if they're better
genetically designed for the sport than
i am if they're technically better and
we're doing the same program
were they or were they technically
better or were you just was that
the insecurity in you speaking either
way it's true okay
right right you know in my head maybe
you know maybe not
um i just felt like i have to find
something else here that exists that
i can somehow latch on to and and dig
and so that's where that kind of
self-exploration became i started
reading about meditation i was
introduced to
kind of visualization when i was 15
through someone who's our sports
psychologist and
that exploratory phase of becoming more
cerebral
and just trying to just trying to find
ways to improve
i think the mental toughness how much
pain i could handle
how much harder i could train really
came through
just a hunger and desire for more
knowledge around the sport and then
trying to break the mold of what people
thought was possible
you know back in 1997 98 99
people would go home during the off
season for three to four months after
the world championships
and i was like why is everybody going
home why don't we just keep training
here in cotto springs
at at altitude like why would i go back
to seattle there's nothing there
there's like no training there there's
no athletes there like i want to stay
here so i decided to stay in the
training center
and that was kind of these small steps
towards
if i can shave off recovery time here if
i can spend more time at altitude if i
can eat a little bit cleaner here if i
can get more rest if i can stay in the
game longer if i can practice
biofeedback training
they just they just seem like all
advantages to me and so
the other athletes in my team trained
very hard and they were very dedicated
and you know if someone was here who's
my teammate they would probably say
apollo works very very hard he was
willing to commit himself
um more than i think probably the rest
of the team i was just obsessed
completely utterly nothing else existed
in my world
except for this kind of psychology of
not an almond more not an almond less
so walk me through a day in training at
the peak
yeah so in terms of like volume of
training it's usually probably kind of
the late summer
so um we're talking you know wake fairly
early
probably around six um jump on the bike
bike to the ice rink um
warm up again just when you were in
colorado springs we were living in the
dorms there i was looking at the dorms
there
um so this is like a typical day in salt
lake city
um where we moved in 2007 to train for
the last three years of my career
um so you know bike to the ice rink
that's about a 27 to 33 minute bike ride
depending if i hit the lights
um and then i get there throw the bike
in the locker room
put my running shoes on run for 35 to 40
minutes
as a warm-up i was already warm just i
mean again this makes no sense
uh go outside and run um come back
inside
do about a half an hour to 40 minutes of
what we call dry land exercises which is
essentially skating imitations off the
ice in your tennis shoes
stretch do some kind of quick like you
know mental checks
throw your racing suit on get out on the
ice train for
two to three hours with the team get off
uh do a stair workout or some kind of
plyometric workout usually on one leg
we do these kind of up the stairs right
next to the ice rink or we find like a
curb and basically just do skating jumps
on this like you know
just to kind of create this
neuromuscular feedback um
and then eat you know refuel
i would then i actually wouldn't eat i
would i would ride my bike back home so
another 33 minutes or so on the bike go
back home
make like two eggs and like some tabasco
or something
and then two hours later i'm back at the
ice rink warming up again
so in that two-hour time period i'm
usually kind of just resting on the
couch
i would watch skating tapes during that
time so i would like visualize like the
times where i felt really good and the
times where i was like that that's it
that's the feeling i want that's that's
right that's where i want to get i'd
watch an athlete who i just
i'd adore the way they skated like i
want to skate like this guy and i would
just
just visualize myself in that moment
then
the afternoon i would i would get on a
bike ride back to the ice rink again
um tennis shoes out again go warm up for
15 to 25 minutes
then easier either have another dry lamp
session or like a you know a fart like
workout
which is you know like we'll do five
minutes of running followed by five
minutes of downtime which is like in the
skating position five minutes running do
that for like 45 minutes or an hour or
we'd have a wait session
you know and then after the wait session
uh we would then jump on the ice
for another hour session usually speed
work at the end of the day
um and then everyone was done everyone's
got the normatec boots on everyone has
got the i
you know everyone is just recovery mode
like everything like wheels are off
your everyone's exhausted i would go
home
and then at the time i hired the
strength of grisham coach to come live
with me
um and we started training additionally
in my house
right because i couldn't get enough um
and then so we would go through like a
third or sometimes a fourth workout
where we would essentially do these
training intervals on the treadmill
and it was just this high-intensity
burst of energy
for like i would say on average about 30
to 45 minutes sometimes up to an hour
then i would jump in the sauna and
meditate and then my day was over
mm-hmm and that was like i mean that you
know you do that enough days
i mean relatively obsessed i would say
pretty obsessed yeah
and it was uh i was obsessed with like
weight
and like you know i i saw what these
tour de france cyclists i'd hear these
stories about guys like going out in
like a
super long bike ride and then coming
home not eating and just going right to
sleep to create kind of more catabolic
activity to kind of
strip away the excess muscle mass that
exists up top was that part of the
pivot in 2010 you dropped like 20 pounds
right
yeah i dropped a significant amount of
weight um the sport was evolving so
in 2002 athletes were much more
anaerobic and we were doing things like
power cleans and power snatches
and you know heavy leg press and heavy
legs and and squats and
um a lot of you know kind of low
repetition but high plyometric movements
so the highest you know everyone was
focused on how fast can you go
and then in 2006 it changed to kind of
more middle distance training so the
south koreans had developed this like
i know everyone's fast but why don't we
just go to like 85 to 95 percent of the
speed like five laps earlier
and basically you know how long can you
maintain 95
of your vo2 max that's like the goal
right like is
that's where the focus of the training
went to yes as opposed to these
explosive off-the-line maneuvers yeah
yeah
and so the efficiency mechanism of your
technique in combination with your body
weight
started to really transform the sport so
guys who were competing in 98 and then
in 2002
they were no longer competitive by sheer
body type they just they
they couldn't they were too heavy they
were too tall uh it started to get much
more sport specific so you
guys started having much less shoulders
and back development and biceps like
that was out the window like
what do you mean you you do curls or put
or benches in the gym like
no one was doing that anymore and we'd
race against these athletes who don't
even lift weights
and they just they're so skinny they
weigh like 116 122 pounds
and they're the same height as me and
then from 2006 to 2010 that became even
more extreme
and what we saw was that the ice
conditions at the olympics would be
would change consistently and we could
never prepare for them and most of the
time
it was very what we call soft which
means a top layer of the ice
doesn't glide as much as you'd like it
to and it doesn't have as much grip
and so power athletes would never
succeed typically
at the olympics because the ice
conditions were such a big part of that
and the athletes that did well were the
athletes that were light and they were
they were they were smooth and they were
technically efficient and so this
obsession we came around
what worked in the previous two olympics
will not work moving forward and
if we need to become competitive i need
to wipe the slate clean
i need to clear my head around this
recipe for success in this blueprint and
create a new one
and kind of look at you know how i could
move was that something
that your teammates were also doing as
well or was that something you took upon
yourself to do
solo i i don't think that my teammates
were doing it in the same movie so like
after the 2009 world championships
instead of staying in salt lake city
i decided to drive my car from salt lake
city to colorado springs kind of where
my career began
and i just lived in the dorms alone and
i trained for like four and a half
months
and just doing these like really insane
workouts i mean i didn't talk to many
people there i was like my saturday
nights were me driving up
into the mountains like looking at the
stars and like
like my treat was like a couple of
pieces of like dark chocolate and like
looking out
and being like you know like is this the
right path am i is this
what i'm supposed to be doing do i still
have it that was a question i used to
ask myself a lot like do i still have
like the mojo like
and you know the feeling right like when
you feel strong and you feel good and
you have that race
and you want to replicate it man there's
nothing better than being in that flow
in that zone and it feels automatic and
easy and
there's nothing better that i've ever
experienced it's like that and i've only
had it a handful of times and i hadn't
had it in many years
in 2007 2008 2009 i haven't felt it i
haven't you know
psychologically felt like i was losing
it and
and the world knew my my self-sabotaging
strategy so they could prepare for it
very easily they knew hey tears two laps
paula's gonna come i'm gonna skate a
very defensive track and so
i just wanted to just basically reinvent
myself
um it was a beautiful time rich it was
man it was
you know sports is awesome because
nothing else exists
except for this moment right life
becomes very simple
yeah very simple but what's
what's also interesting is is that
your teammates and your friends are also
the same people
vying for that olympic slot right yeah
in
in short track what like six guys make
the team or something like that like
yeah
only the tiniest number of people get to
go
so these people that you're training
with are also your competitors
yeah you spend you know 10 years your
life training with your team
and and pushing each other and making
sure everyone is
is trying to be their best and then you
know
you have a one weekend window where
everyone's vying
for the same spot everyone wants to
compete you know if you want to compete
in an individual distance at the
olympics then you have to be top two in
that distance at the olympic trials
and some people peak early some people
don't peak at all
and it's it's it there's been
relationships shattered
because of the olympic trials right it's
like how what do you mean
that we've been brother and sister this
whole time
right and then you i just tried to pass
you and you basically threw an elbow in
my face
and i fell and my olympic team dreams
are over
right i will never forgive you for the
rest of your life for that you know and
it's that that's happened or guys who
have trained their whole life the week
of olympic trials they fall in break and
ankle right i mean it's just
stuff like that is it makes me wonder
like how did i
train all those years and actually never
get hurt how did i
fall how how did i not fall and and
so i just considered myself very very
lucky in that right yeah well you had
you had your crashes though less than
opportune moments
i did right um let's talk about
intentionality i know that
in in swimming you may you may train
four hours a day but every workout two
hour workout
there'll be a main set or maybe two main
sets and that main set
really boils down to perhaps that final
interval
and the workout's really all about that
so it's about being
aware and present and available for
those specific
opportunities and moments and i suspect
it's no different in speed skating so
talk a little bit about the approach to
training the intentionality that you
have to take to it
and how that translates into you know
how you
how do you carry that into the world i
love intentionality and i love
this is what i talk to the team now
about is you know this younger
generation who's training in short track
i say like you know what is your
intention on day to day basis it's very
easy for you to fall on the routine of
doing the same workouts on monday
tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday
and just doing the same thing every
single week and you kind of get lost in
the cycle of
normalcy and you're in the i call it the
green zone right this is green light
everything is comfortable
you know i know this road before here's
my markers i know i should be starting
to get tired around this kind of lap
time
and so what what i felt was and what i
was trained
from all the sports psychologists that i
was able to kind of go down and then all
the books that i was reading
um whether it was an eastern philosophy
or kind of the battle is always within
um your intention that you set for that
particular workout
greatly indicates the outcome in some
capacity and i just i saw
huge jumps in my performance when i was
intentionally
going to the ice rink with a specific
task and a purpose for what i was doing
versus going through the motions and not
really understanding why i'm doing this
training
and what is that how much of that is
about your relationship with the coach
and the communication that you have well
it's it's huge the why
the why is very important yeah and so
you know in short track speed skating a
sport which is dominated by
uh many of the asian countries the
cultural norm
in asia is the coach is kind of like the
king
and he just tells the athletes what to
do the athletes don't they don't
talk back they don't question they just
do it's just
i say this you go do it and me being
this like
you know american kid and having a south
korean coach and him yelling at me to do
anything i'm saying well hold on
why are we doing this training today
what energy system are we training
i just needed to know and understand now
if the hardness was okay
i'm okay going hard that's not a problem
i need to know what is the purpose
where does this fit into the overall
plan and then i think once my teammates
started to understand that they too were
much more willing to accept these
impossibilities these impossible
workouts that were set forth
before us right and then how do
how does that translate in the real
world
so i think it translates in the real
world to
an even greater degree right um
no matter what career path you're you're
going down or you're making a big change
it's
very easy to fall into the same patterns
and routines that
feel normal to you because they signal
this sense of control
to reach for the handful of those peanut
m ms which was like my thing my issue
right or whatever that kind of
self-sabotage is
it creates a sense of even though i know
i'm doing this i know it's not good for
me i'm still going to do it because it
gives me this subconscious level of
control in some capacity
you got to break that cycle and so
having the intention
multiple times a day and being
consistent with it is so important in
terms of how you live your life
um i mean i feel it now rich in terms of
you know i'm driven i think by something
much different than what existed before
in sport
and it's less about fear of failure and
it's less about winning and it's more
about
how can i help people also feel the same
level of kind of
fulfillment and happiness when you're
able to achieve beyond what you thought
was possible
previously and how did you make that
pivot because that's a pretty dramatic
shift from
when it all costs i'm never going to let
anyone beat me to
a more service-minded approach to how
you live
i think it was a it's been a i consider
it to be a 10 year
in probably going on a 20 year and then
30 year journey that i work on
every day um i think a lot of that had
to do with coming to terms with
who i was as an athlete
the core tenants and the core principles
that helped me
succeed and then using some of those
core tenants
and applying them towards the next path
but then just recognizing that
i wasn't in a stagnant state that i grow
empathy was not something that came
naturally to me
and i don't know if this is because of
being in a single parent household
having a father and not having a mother
i'm sure that there's some correlation
there in some capacity and then so
just being more just being more
inquisitive about like
man like life is short am i living this
life to the best of my ability
am i living this life to help benefit
not only myself which is very easy
because i'm in a selfish olympic sport
which is about
yourself but how do i do it in a way
that people can
can thrive and learn and embrace their
insecurities and understand them and
then turn them into these incredible
opportunities for growth
because i felt it i felt those feelings
of insecurity i felt those fears of
failure i felt that kind of
lack of i'm not good enough i'll never
be good enough
there's this obsessive nature that's
beautiful on one side and i believe it's
necessary in certain elements of your
life
but it has to be controlled in a way
that is healthy and
i think that so to answer your question
you know this process that i've
that i'm continually going down and i'm
learning all the time about myself and
and people
like you who are intentional about
talking about this openly i think that's
where it starts is
taking the layers of armor off and
recognizing that you're human and you
live on this planet you're having an
experience
and the choices that you make on a daily
basis
um can be within your control regardless
of the circumstances that you're in
whether you've been put there by your
own complicit nature doesn't really
matter and so
i became very obsessed with not only
personal development but really
just feeling like what basically it was
like this i was chasing dreams that were
taught to me at a very young age that
this is what it means to be successful
and this is what it means because you
are a champion
and you're different and therefore this
is what you deserve
and those are external signals that like
they feel like they're very easy for me
to go on that road and say yeah that
makes sense i i get it like that's the
direction i should go and then there's a
bigger question which i feel very lucky
and grateful because i've had people in
my life
force me to ask those questions and and
i would ask them for an answer and they
would respond back with a question
right and i was like what the hell is
this like my dad does that
and and i think that inquisitive nature
i just i found it to be just so deeply
satisfying
to see and recognize that there's people
in this world who
may have not been olympic athletes but
their stories are so compelling
and they're fascinating and they're
interesting and
the human spirit is just so beautiful
and so i just want to help people
unlock that spirit unlock that that
fire that olympic mindset that exists
within them
and it's in every human in some capacity
and we may not even some people go their
entire lives and never even
feel it taste it touch it see it they
don't even know that it's there
because they've been conditioned in
another realm of telling them that
you can't do this because you're not
this is not this is not what you're
supposed to do
and hey genetics are a big part of sport
you know
natural tendencies that do certain
things are are we know some people are
amazing artists
naturally i'm not saying that i'm just
saying that i felt a deeper connection
to people in general after after my
experiences in sport
and i look back on that and i say well
you know what are the things that helped
me
kind of achieve these things that people
thought were impossible in the world of
the olympics
and how can i teach others maybe not
teach the right word how can i guide
others
in a way through my own setbacks and
experiences so that they can come to
their own realization and recognize that
man i've been searching
all over the world and all over the
internet for these answers
and all along i actually had the answer
and it was deep within my own psyche and
my own self and i had to go through this
process in order to feel like that so
and what are those principles if you had
to define them
that are teachable so the principles and
i think everyone has kind of their own
set of what this is and i call it the
five golden principles
um i think number one is for me has been
gratitude
um you know sport like short track speed
skating you run the same race i said
before four times you get four different
winners
anything can happen at any moment um be
grateful for the opportunity that you
have
um if you are living if you are
breathing if you are here if you have a
family if you have a second chance
um that that gratitude power is very
real
and uh i would win races rich in the
past and i wasn't grateful
and i i so how did you come into a place
of embracing that
from you know the punk kid with all the
talent
who was erratic into somebody who could
appreciate
the opportunity through failure
through just banging my head against
a particular path or or journey or
decision and and not winning
and then recognizing hey like you have
you've been you've been given such a
gift
um to thrive in this planet
and and don't don't throw this away you
don't have to self-sabotage
so that that kind of gratitude and being
grateful and being present
i used to keep my medals in like the
sock drawer right because i was like i
never wanna
i don't wanna be that i don't i don't
wanna look at them and gloat i don't
wanna look at them and have them feel
like i've arrived
i wanna keep the kind of underdog
mentality and at some point it's like
hey
why don't i look what i actually took
them out this is like you know since
covet
um started i started looking at them i
was like man this is i've actually never
even looked at these
what the hell really is so crazy right
um
i'm just so deathly afraid of of of
going down that path
and then finally as hey of ego
attachment to that or
this idea that that you're trying to
distance yourself from that because you
want a new definition of who you are
that isn't related to that past
i mean both and i've come to terms with
the fact that like people
you know may always see me as apollo oh
no dancing with the stars uh-huh
and that's okay like before like you
don't even know that you really pissed
me off eight olympic medals
yeah no or they know they don't care
paul that's great that's great tell me
more about the dancing with julianne
huff right
so you know that the gratitude process
was something that i think
i i work on daily and i think it's
something that you have to be consistent
in terms of your habits and setting
it's a practice it's a practice it is a
true practice and
gratitude's tough right because it
starts with like you know the three
levels of like feeling
and then you start to do and then it
goes kind of deeper
and the second so the five golden
principles are
number one is gratitude the second one
is giving i think giving
both in terms of others time energy
resources whatever that is
giving yourself a chance to really
thrive i think a lot of people hold
themselves back
and they they usually kind of hold
themselves back because of their own
self-sabotage
just like i did in my own life third
part is grit
i think you know we live in a society
which really rewards
instantaneous feedback right away and i
think recognizing that sometimes you
won't have the answers right away and
that it's gonna be painful and it's not
going to feel good
and that's okay that's a part of this
resistance right at some point
my friend was telling me the other day
it's like going in terms like a rubber
band
you're like going back going back and
then you're letting go and all of a
sudden you're just hurtling through the
air and you don't know when that let go
is
but you just so you feel like you've
been going up against this resistance
for so long
so sometimes going towards the fire is
where you can really find
who your true self is um and then the
the fourth is kind of gearing up your
personal expectations so if you've
created some kind of
self-forming habit that is really
detracting away from what you want in
life
and what life wants from you you gotta
you gotta change that immediately and
you have to consistently hammer
away and mitigate the natural tendency
to go towards what was normal before and
that
only comes to repetition and practice
there's no hack shortcut it just
the human brain you know i mean you had
andrew on the other day which i thought
was really fascinating
that's how human brain works and so
you've got to form the new habit to make
that the new normal yeah
and the fifth um is just getting into
action just going
and just doing it because the paralysis
by analysis is real
it certainly is my friend so what what
is the
like what would be an example of of how
you're applying that in your life now
like where are your blind spots and
what are the challenges that you're
still trying to overcome
oh man you have you have a couple days
yeah i've got
plenty of time go as long as you want
i uh i face challenges with all five of
those principles
every day but i have them written down
they're on my desk
they're part of my daily routine in the
morning they're part of my daily routine
in the evening
and even even then there's times
when i misstep and i don't do them and i
don't be intentional about what that
looks like
and that's okay um i have a beautiful
fiance
who has kind of reminded me time and
time again
of these simple things that we should
and are grateful for and there's times
when i'll be out for a run
or i'll be doing something kind of solo
in nature and i'll kind of just smile
and be like god she is so right
she is so right why am i chasing
that thing again why am i chasing that
elusive feeling that i
thought would make me happy but it's got
nothing to do with it
it's really got nothing to do with it so
yeah it's interesting
that as somebody who has achieved such
heights
of success that it's still a challenge
for you to realize that that's not the
answer
right to the wholeness that you seek or
the sense of
personal satisfaction and it it's a it's
a personal
journey and a feeling right it's hard
for people to kind of
articulate what these emotions feel like
when they're going through them
and you know i think that many things in
our life we've
tried to control to the most detail in
minutia
and being able to say i can't i can't
control all the aspects
and looking at life more of as an
adventure
versus a script although i love the idea
of writing your own
story and being your own hero but the
growth is in the letting go
going from this very controlled
environment where it's all about
minimizing the variables into embracing
the fact that there are variables you
will
you will never control it and and
developing a comfort with that
right letting go is is that's a
challenge that i have
i still i i'm always drawn back to that
kind of
i've got you know 25 years of
conditioning that i'm trying to break on
a daily basis
and what is this so what is the practice
like you said you wrote it down
did you write down you're writing down
the things that you're challenged by or
the actual practices that you
undertake every day so the practices
that i undertake on a daily basis are
pretty ingrained where i don't need to
write them down
i'm going to do them naturally um kind
of you know i call it to kind of
how do i prime and set my day intention
wise
for the remainder and then how do i wind
down that day and reflect upon what just
happened what what well what didn't go
well
how can i improve for tomorrow what am i
happy for um
you know kind of those those attributes
and then
the the letting go aspect is really
tough though it's something that i i
struggle with
often letting go of a previous identity
right i'm learning to to reinvent being
okay with
people labeling and identifying you as
one particular thing and just saying
that that's all right
that's totally cool instead of like
being like hey why don't you recognize
me as this or i'm
so much more why can't let me tell you
all the cool things that i am doing
let me explain how cool i am like that
it's easy to fall victim to that and uh
so it's been fun i mean the the the life
journey of
of learning and growing and and you know
and sharing with others
kind of the vulnerabilities that exist
within
these super human feats of performance
that exist in the olympic space
uh but then also got it going deeper in
terms of that mindset and
and how we can curate different
experiences for ourselves if we really
desire them
what are some of the books that were
instrumental
in this process for you and the first
book that was instrumental for me
um was a dan millman book
um the way of the peaceful warrior
classic yeah i thought that was a really
fascinating book
there's a book that i recently read
about
um by francis fukuyama
called identity i actually was going to
send this to you because i was watching
one of your podcasts a while ago when
you were talking about some of the
political strifes that exist in the
country
and i felt like this author and his
20-year work
understands how we got to where we are
today
and he talks a lot about kind of the
recognition
identity that exists and the fight for
why
people have this massive polarization
and beliefs and siding with
um you know political ideas and
uh anyway identity it's called identity
it's a short read but i thought it was
fascinating to me it helped me
understand
why why certain parts of the country or
why certain people believe what they
believe in and what are they fighting
for what do they believe that they're
fighting for
um and then which ideologies and which
things do i
hold to myself that i think are true but
maybe aren't
yeah um and so that was interesting and
then i've just been deeply obsessed i
think with
more lately around i think much more
around the kind of the eastern
philosophical
uh viewpoints and understandings and
they've kind of
helped poke some holes in my previously
conceived beliefs around
my path uh my control over my path
and i i just i love the fact that
you know i believe that i have control
over my path
uh-huh like i i when i say that i
believe it
and then when i read these you know
these like ancient texts and scripts
from these amazing philosophers from
around the planet
and they're like there's so much of this
world that you don't control
you're not you know like it is a weird
disorienting thing and as an
athlete it's all about controlling your
destiny your fate is in your hands it's
up to you
how hard are you going to work how much
do you want it
and then grappling reckoning with these
broader truths about our place in the
world
and how little control we have and how
so much can be learned
in the letting go process and how that
can actually
foster the evolution that you seek and
and and fill some of those holes that
perhaps didn't get filled through sport
and accolades and all the other things
that you were chasing as a younger man
and the journey never stops right it
just it continues and it continues and
i think you know when i look back in my
career it's
i think that there was times like this
is it like i this is it
this is the pinnacle of life it doesn't
get better than this moment
um i've got thousands and millions of
people screaming and sharing
my name and team usa and this is this is
the most important thing in the universe
that exists today
right right and then like you know and
then coming and spending time in los
angeles and then traveling around the
world and getting different perspectives
and being anonymous in asia
and people looking at me as just like
some long-haired dude who like walk in
this room right unless you go to south
korea
then they recognize me yeah pretty fast
yeah um that's a different thing it's a
different story yeah uh
it's it it's just i find it fascinating
and you know i know that you've kind of
done
you've done a lot of deep work on
yourself and your path and
man there's there's i've always wondered
why do companies and organizations and
schools
not teach more about kind of the
very important raw elements of growth as
a human
and we learn about these you know
fundamentals which i think are important
and they're obviously necessary but like
when you join a nice corporate gig and a
job no one teaches you how to be a
better human
they just teach you how to do your job
better or what they think to do your job
what if i what if they taught you these
elements of
this is gratitude this is how you give
to yourself and to others
this is what grit is really all about
this is what you're going to face
during your career here and it's going
to be okay you know this is about how we
expect you to gear up your personal
expectations both
at the office or virtually and at home
because we want you to thrive at home so
when you come into work you're better
and then how do you
put all this stuff together you know
like well 100
it should be taught to young people and
it should be part of
any kind of ongoing education for any
human being but
wisdom has to meet willingness you know
it's sort of like
when you were a young athlete and you
were sitting
at the training center or whatever
wherever you were you were telling the
story of
being told like okay you need to start
thinking about your life outside of the
olympics like you weren't ready to
receive that
information at that time so we could
teach these things
my i you know i suspect that for a lot
of young people they're not going to be
interested in it it's not until you get
older
where these things become relevant
enough where we seek them out in our
life but
you know i think that we need a
wholesale revolution of our education
system
to pivot away from this kind of
victorian era
of memorization etc
towards learning how to be more fully
actualized human beings and how to be
good team members and listeners and
you know life learners as opposed to
test takers
and even even not even in the in the
younger generation even
if you go to any corporate environment
now you can kind of count on a handful
in a boardroom of how many people have
actually sought out real true
kind of personal growth and development
and understanding of self
i feel like that's changing though i
mean you're somebody who does a lot of
public speaking right so you go to these
corporations and you get to spend time
with these people
and you know i don't know if that
existed 20 years ago where these
companies have a budget that they set
aside for bringing people like yourself
in
to you know help them with that so i
feel like that's becoming more
a part of the kind of curriculum of
these larger
organizations that are around like how
to how to sort of
be well outside of the office
so i think that's a good thing but
certainly a lot of work remains to be
done
and we hope that you know the one
positive element of
these circumstances the globe is facing
right now is that people are taking time
to recognize what's really important to
them
trying to find sense of purpose and
meaning in whatever career path that
they're currently in
and as people go through this this
transition or this reinvention or
hard pivot they can find ways in which
they can start to really start to dive
deeper into
who am i what's important how do i how
do i impact
more how do i show up in a different
energy in
a way that is bright and highlights the
things that i care about
and and maybe that's the the path
forward is that these organizations are
going to say hey look we may have cut
50 of our workforce but those who are
remaining
we're willing to say hey we want to
reinvest back in you
and it's got nothing to do over here
with what you're doing in your business
it's got everything to do as you as a
human being
how you live your life at home and we
want you to thrive in that environment
i mean i did that that to me like i
would love love that when i was
competing and just say hey paul what are
you doing when we don't see you during
the day
right like are you healthy is everything
okay like are you going home and just
being like this like
manic insane obsessive guy who like
can't stop thinking about the sport
or is there maybe is there a better path
here is there like another way that we
can train you to give you some distance
and give you and to
you know disengage for a second then
come back and you're refreshed and
hungry and happy
and more willing to train in more
specific environments
and just like i think in maybe you know
the world that we have to have those
times of
complete detachment away from the rat
race
and spend time in nature and go out and
some of us don't even have access to
those things right because we're just
people are
are trying to put food on the table and
they feel like they are just
the gun is there right and they have to
keep going well this forced moment
is forcing us to confront that
you know my hope is that you know people
can
identify a silver lining in it and an
opportunity
and uh you know a a way to find
some level of gratitude in the
experience which is
very hard for a lot of people like i'm
you know look i'm speaking from a place
of great privilege i get to do what i do
for a living etc
a lot of people are losing their jobs
it's very difficult out there for a lot
of people but
to the extent that there is
um you know some opportunity to be had
here
i think that you know helping people
recognize that
is worthy of discussion
whether it's something personal like
when we're forced to stop
then suddenly we have to confront
ourselves in a way that's uncomfortable
and i think that that is part of all the
kind of vitriol that we're seeing
played out in social media where people
are entrenched in their
particular points of view and expressing
that in
unhealthy ways you know across the board
uh to the extent that we can refrain
from that and reflect
internally on ourselves and how we can
be better and how we can
use this moment to reimagine what we
want our lives to be
and that's that's a luxury i understand
that but i think
even if it's five minutes for somebody
in a day to be able to use this
moment for that purpose would be a win
very well said i don't know i like that
i can't let you leave though without
talking about the iron man
you did that in 2014 yeah yeah 2014.
that was
how did that all come about for sprinter
yeah a sprinter trained like an
endurance athlete though so the iron man
came about
i mean to be honest it came out because
a sponsor had come on board
and said hey do you want to run the
ironman and i'm like no
absolutely not no i've heard many
stories about that that is not what this
body type is designed for
um and i also heard i i also
read that like the human cells age like
20 years or something during the course
of the iron that's not true and then
they recover
and someone told me some kind of metric
or something associated like there's so
much damage done and obviously you
bounce back and it's okay but
anyway so i said no um and then finally
i said yes
i think i just got this like deeper
desire to like try things that
i've just never done before and
uh and then i recognize also the kind of
uniqueness of having a slot
at kona which i didn't really understand
what it was until i started
having friends and other triathletes
telling me he's like hey man you know
like
like this is really hard to get into
number one and number two like
don't take this lightly like this is
this is pretty serious like yeah
sorry i started asking friends like well
how fast can i go and they're like i
don't know
don't worry about it but probably not
very fast right like like we've ridden
with you like we've ran with you like
you can't know your capability
yeah um well you came from a swimming
background you rode your bike for your
training
you were it wasn't like you didn't have
experience in these disciplines
i had experience but nothing in that
degree and then that kind of
zone of heart rate for that duration and
in that heat
which was the biggest issue there but i
i got to tell you
i loved it it was it opened my eyes
i always thought when i say you guys i
mean like
endurance athletes and ultra endurance i
was like you guys are just completely
insane
like this is what do you mean you're
gonna go for a 20-mile run
today like i just i couldn't you know we
do two by
ten times you know 150 meters like
that's our track workout
you know and then like long periods of
rest so it was it was unique and
i loved it i i was given this coach who
was going to help me train for the
ironman and like i think it was like
seven months her name was paula newby
fraser i'm sure you know paula of course
um and she was she was just amazing she
understood me
as an athlete she understood my
psychology she knew how to kind of hold
the reins back and
and she just helped create this amazing
training program yeah because for a guy
like you
it's it it's going to have to be about
holding you back
right because you're going to want to
just go train
30 hours a week right out of the gate
right and you'll end up
yeah and all in the wrong like energy
systems right right not training like i
just want to go climb mountains and do
hill sprints uh-huh you know she's like
no no we're not gonna do that we're just
gonna go ride for like two and a half
hours where i'm gonna look at the watts
we're just gonna go ride and just put
your body in there and
you know just four years into my
retirement i had i had been heavier much
heavier than i had liked to have been
right at that time i'd been traveling a
lot my diet was
all over the place i was experimenting
and eating everything and anything
in asia and in europe and all over the
you just i just was living my life
so i thought right and then this
opportunity came and it kind of helped
me
redial in my love for athletics
and spending time on a bike with no
headphones for hours at a time is
you know you have a lot of internal
conversations and it was beautiful
so a lot of the people that get those i
mean it's essentially
a celebrity spot right like you get
gifted this spot you didn't have to
qualify for the race they just allow you
to have it
a lot of the people that are in that
position they just kind of
you know don't take it seriously and
show up and somehow get through it but
this i have a different i have a sense
that you actually took it seriously and
in that seven month period you really
wanted to see
how well you could do because that's
fundamentally how you're wired
i think i took it seriously as i could
um still traveling a lot but i it
i recognized the value of that slot and
i didn't
there's two things one i deeply
respected the endurance community
because i just these guys they did
things that i could never
believe that i could do and i was just i
just thought it was you know this is
what they train their entire lives for
so it'd be like if someone was given a
slot to go try the olympic trials
i'm like hey man you better if you were
given the slot like show me show me i
don't even care how good you are just
show me that you put in the time and
energy associated so that's what i
wanted to do so it's out of respect for
the existing community
and then two there's something beautiful
and magical about training for those
longer endurance races
and it i hadn't felt that feeling since
i had been training for the olympics and
so it was this amazing opportunity that
i didn't want to waste and
and i found a lot of kind of deeper
answers that i was actually searching
for about
what it was to go and compete in in an
iron man
um and it was awesome and and the iron
man competition is you know unless
you're a pro
it's really until then it's really just
about yourself you know like and i i
love that
yeah it's certainly not about anybody
else which makes it different from
short track in a lot of ways and just
the fact that
it's about economy and efficiency it's
about making sure your heart rate
doesn't go
over a certain thing that was so strange
as opposed to trying to see how high you
can get it that was you know
i i used to oh we would be riding our
bikes and i'd be with paula and she'd be
like you know like how do you feel i'm
like good like i don't feel any lactate
she's like you're not supposed to
right if you do then you're gonna have
to slow down
i mean we're used to like feeling
lactate in our teeth you know like just
right being in the state of just pure
pain but it was
man you know kona and just reliving that
moment kind of waking up very early
and going out there and they don't they
the
the locals they beat these drums at the
beginning of the race and you've got the
pros the guys who are going to do these
amazing you know speed um completion of
this iron man and
everyone's in the same water the same
time i was like man this is
this is unlike anything i've ever
experienced this is really cool and yeah
it's pretty unique in that way
it was really beautiful and then being
out there in the queen k and
it was man it was it was hard it was
many times i cracked um
you got it done though got it done that
that's that was the purpose and
it wasn't until by the way halfway
through the race i was like
what the hell am i doing and then the
last six miles of the run
uh you know in the end i was like i get
it i get why people
do this so much like i i unders this
feeling that i have right now is
maybe perhaps what what they're all
feeling every time
and it was it was a very addictive
feeling yeah
this uh olympic swimmer friend of mine
sprinter garrett weber gayle what's up
garrett
uh asked me one time a long time ago he
said do you what do you think is
what do you think is harder do you think
it's harder to swim the 50 freestyle
or to like
compete in the iron man and i thought
about it because it's an interesting
question yeah
and i think the answer is that they're
both hard like if you want to be
the best if you want to be a master of
either of those disciplines it will
require all of you
the 50 freestyle is 18 seconds or
whatever it is
the iron man is gonna take you know for
the best people seven and a half hours
or whatever that is
to reach that potential in each of those
is going to have to
meet their maker in an equal way you
know and as somebody who
you know has done both how do you think
about the difference in those
disciplines they're
they're both very hard and
you know if if you said to me paul you
have to go train
for a living for the iron man
i i would be very concerned that i could
actually be competitive
um i just you know i'm very good but
well you're wired as a sprinter
why is a sprinter wired as a power
athlete why does this like you know
lacked a capacity threshold
type of um of a skater it was
it was different it was really different
definitely transformed my body and it
and absolutely trained the sprint out of
me um
which is fine i did yes you lost all
your power and your strength
i mean i didn't have i lost it all but i
definitely cannot jump anywhere as high
um afterwards and i had continued the
training on for like another year after
because i became very addicted to that
feeling and
uh but it was training for an olympic
race you know
that is 40 seconds long and you have to
be absolutely perfect in that realm
you know the tenths of a second
hundredths of a second thousands of a
second is the difference between winning
and
not making the podium sometimes and then
being out there
on on during an ironman and
you know like seconds still matter
i mean they still matter and to me the
psychological game is the same
it's still very much the same and kind
of the hardening of the mind when you're
out there and seeing
you know when i was competing in the
iron man i i stopped
doing the race pace that we had set
forth um which was like around
10 hours and 20 minutes or something
like that's what paula wanted me to do
and i
deeply wanted to break 10 hours because
a triathlon
triathlete friend of mine told me i
never would uh-huh i asked him i was
like well what happens if i break 10
hours because don't worry you won't you
will
and so i was like okay and
i just i wanted to see you know i'm
i have become addicted to seeing what
that that threshold is and where that
limit is it's pretty easy to push
yourself to
to exhaustion right and find things to
do
that are really challenging but the iron
man was tough because of that that heat
was just
so brutal and that humidity and then you
know having that
the experience of the energy lab and
then like looking forward to it as you
run down to that area and being like all
right i'm here let's
like let's do this um i hadn't had
anything in my life
like that for like four years the queen
case so disorienting too
because you things are so far apart but
you think they're closer than they are
like there's an optical illusion that
that takes place on that road for some
reason
yeah that plays head games with you for
sure
what kind of head games happened with
you when you were doing your five well
i've never done the iron man actually i
did i've done the ultraman a couple
times which takes place on this
it's a three-day race double iron man
that goes all the way around the big
island
um and i've trained a lot on the big
island the third day is a
is a 52 mile run from javi to the old
airport which is basically
right by the pier where the iron man
starts so i've spent a lot of time on
that on that road
training and also racing and what kind
of conversations are happening
in your head oh i mean you know come on
all kinds of insanity that uh
well listen you know you know as
somebody who who
not only is an olympic athlete but as
somebody who trained for the iron man
you're spending all this time alone with
yourself and just you and your thoughts
right so you become very connected to
all the stories that you tell yourself
about what you're capable of and what
you're not and also where your mind
tends to linger when you're not paying
attention
and i think for me
that process has been incredibly
instrumental
as a growth tool like all that time
alone where you're with yourself and i
was doing that at a moment in my life
when
i was trying to figure out who i was and
what i wanted to do and who i wanted to
be i was at a transitionary
phase of my professional career and how
i thought about myself
and that time alone was really this
gestation period that allowed me to work
through a lot of that confusion in my
life
and i think it's a big reason why you
know i was able to answer a lot of those
questions for myself
by virtue of the training and
you know probably wouldn't be sitting
here talking to you today had i not done
that stuff so
i think they're tools you know i think
they're tools i think they can be
leveraged for personal growth
or as you know as well as anybody they
can be used to
run away from your life as well you know
there's that
trope in iron man like oh that the iron
man widow or whatever there's a lot of
people
who can use endurance sports as a way of
not dealing
with their life as a as a sort of a
denial mechanism so i think it's all
about your
relationship to it yeah it's like a it's
like a
beautiful sword that is a tool that
could carve
you know amazing things or it can cut
you very deeply
self-inflicted so tell me about the book
yeah so the book has been many years
kind of in the making the book is soft
titled
hard pivot and it started out as a
journal
of me kind of writing down my thoughts
around
this very difficult transition that was
happening
from my what i thought was my only
identity into
trying to find what my next identity was
the struggles and the trials and
tribulations of why i made certain
mistakes why i made the same mistakes
over and over again
in in certain different paths with
different people
and then trying to find a better path
forward a more productive and a
healthier path
both psychologically and also i think
physically and emotionally and
spiritually
and that led me down the path of
we all are reinventing ourselves you
know whether it's every seven years
whether it's every couple of years
we're always reinventing in some
capacity and i became
very interested in why certain people
have had a tremendous amount of success
reinventing themselves when others have
failed miserably
or myself have kind of not tried and not
been able to figure out like how can i
thrive and receive the same type of
satisfaction that i was receiving before
i was so good at doing these things i've
got these attributes in my pocket that
are transferable across any career path
like why is it not clicking for me
and then that led me towards having
conversations with athletes and business
women and businessmen
and artists and entertainers and people
from all over the globe and planet
around like what makes you tick
like what what is the driving force is
it the micro trauma
how do you reinvent is there a better
path how does gratitude
play a role what are the five golden
principles for you personally one of
those things may be totally different
and it was really this younger it's this
memoir
it started out as this young is this
memoir to a younger apollo
say hey look you're going to screw up a
lot
throughout your career and post career
and i hope that this book can give you
some tools and strategies
and just some insights around what to
potentially expect from both yourself
and from the world and the way that you
interact with it and the way that you
play in this world the way that you work
in this world the way that you
live your life and there is no
right path for you it's just a choice
that you make
and there's obstacles and challenges and
how you turn them into opportunities is
solely within your perception
and so it's a blend of kind of this
psychological
um kind of conversation that i had with
myself
and kind of the dark places that i went
to around why i was
forming these bad habits around whether
it was bad business partners
bad businesses running away going to
asia because i didn't want to
i didn't want to be here in the states
facing the identity of what apollo owner
was here
because i was recognized in you know
checkouts or driving or whatever that
was
and i was very hungry to form a new
identity and then
hearing the stories from other athletes
who also struggled in the same way
um and was like man that guy didn't win
any medals and he feels literally
identical to the way that i felt
and i started talking to people who
weren't olympic athletes and started
hearing from them about
their own personal struggles and
reinvention and feeling like they've
lost everything
mentally and physically and they've
they've got no skill set in how they
move forward and so
that led me to believe that god there's
got to be a set of people in population
of this world
who are going to feel like this or who
have already felt like this or perhaps
looking for
some additional guidance in terms of how
to
choose better how to live better how to
create changes that stick that are there
and that can resonate with you that are
important to you
um and how to have deeper introspective
questions with yourself
that are really hard to do because that
means looking in the mirror and
yeah and knowing that you're human which
means you are
full of flaws um and that's an ongoing
book that i'm writing and it's one that
i hope will
i think just resonate with individuals
and people who are looking for a change
and recognize that whatever was done
before
is not gonna work moving forward um and
then
having that light switch turn on which
we've seen in friends and family all
around us
of people who've been that man or woman
on fire they're a changed person
um and that to me is like that inspires
me
so hopefully that can show them not as
like i'm not speaking from a place of
being like i'm the guru i've figured it
out
it's more of here's what has worked for
me here's what i know has not worked for
me
here's what these people have said about
how they live their life and the
experiences associated
and here's how you can draw from those
things because i think as human beings
we're connected to each other in a
certain way that
is potentially sometimes unexplainable
but we
we want to get drawn to those stories we
want to
hear from those and create these similar
paths and say i i feel what that guy is
feeling or
i know what she went through because i i
had the same type of feeling or
background or childhood
um and we crave them and so that's what
the book is
yeah yeah that's cool no i gather that
it it comes from this
genuine authentic place of being
informed by your own struggles with this
right
and and the reflection of of
understanding that you went to asia
as much to run away as as much as it was
to pursue these entrepreneurial
ventures right like that's that's like
maturation to recognize that because it
would be easy to say oh i'm doing this
for a business this is what i need to do
but
to understand that you were
to some extent running away from
yourself in so doing
i think speaks to somebody who's done
the work
like you've done quite a bit of work to
get to that place
yeah i've done a lot of work what did
you what what did you learn in talking
to all these people that you didn't know
going into this project
i think i knew them going in the project
the thing that seemed like the
similarity and the tone amongst
everybody was
everyone's path was very hard at some
point
and so hard to where they really
questioned why they were doing it or if
there was going to be something that was
going to turn the corner
i just had a conversation a couple of
days ago where someone was saying that
there was this inner voice that kept
telling him and reminding him that his
work was not over
and that even though he was tired and
exhausted and he was running a different
business he started another one this new
business was the one
that he didn't look at as a business he
was helping people with their own pain
and i was like man that's so much like
what is this inner voice and you know is
it religion is it spirituality is it
like your own inner god like
what was this voice and he's like i
don't know
and this this man was very emotional
when he was telling me the story
he would just he just checks in with it
like is this it
is this the right path that i'm going
towards and so what i noticed is that
people were having that kind of
conversation
not everyone but the ones that i really
felt like
kind of understood it and did some work
um
they were having these conversations
like is this the path
um it's like connected to their
intuition connected to that
i call it the inner voice right your
true north your your compass
like is this it like am i doing this for
the right reasons
in the right time frame and is this
important to me is this important to my
family is important to the world
um and sometimes it's hard to answer
that question like if you're like an
accountant
and you're like is this is what i'm
doing right now important like in the
whole grand scheme of like sometimes the
world physics is going to implode
and i don't know that the the answer to
that but what i saw was a similarity was
that everyone had this introspective
resistance and challenge and the ones
who had success were the ones who were
able to either stick with it or pivot
and continue on that kind of consistent
um drive towards something is greater
than myself
and i believe that's important to what
i'm doing um and then there
and then there was others who were like
i just this is i love what i'm doing
and and that was interesting too right
is people who had this
natural curiosity of just growth and
those
those are the ones that seem to me were
masters at reinvention
like they just were like it looked like
they had the midas touch
and then upon deeper analysis
they didn't have the midas touch it's
just the way they spoke about their
experiences
and their perceptions of the challenges
that they had
made it seem like they had the modest
touch and they were winning and they
genuinely felt that
so that's interesting yeah because i'm
i'm typically
jealous of those people you know like
take like uh
like a musician for example somebody who
picks up a guitar at a very young age
and that's just their thing and they do
that their whole life and they love it
and
eventually they're able to craft a
career around it
versus someone like yourself an athlete
there's a shelf life on that passion
at some point you're gonna have to give
it up and you know that sucks
right why couldn't it be something like
guitar that you could do for the rest of
your life
right i i love musicians and artists
because it just it seems like the purest
form of expression right
you're up there and but but i agree i
think that there's
look the world is is full of of the face
that you give to the world the face that
you face in the mirror and the face when
there is no mirror and there's no one
else around
and i think the deeper that you can
understand those three phases of the
face
and get closer to the one face is that i
think the happier
we all can be you know i've got apollo
the speed skater
um the kind of this this you know this
person who represents certain things
that we like about the olympic space
is dancing with the stars character this
entrepreneur
um and then there's this person who
exists beneath that layer behind the
curtain
like who is that person does that person
resonate with each one of these
personalities that on an external view
or looking in at
and then how do i form a more holistic
and full-bodied understanding of
who am i like what do i want in this
world and what does this world want from
me and how can i
impact this world even in the smallest
of micro
seconds in someone's day to where they
can for a second say ah
i know what he's feeling i know what
that is i know i should be doing this
and i can do something about it um
and that to me is this driving force now
that i think is
taking that relentless drive that
existed about something that was
very personal and and selfish in a sense
right i want to win a gold medal for me
um and then saying like i want to help
people win their own gold medals
in their own personal lives and do it
for the right reasons
and and that that that seems like an
impossible task that i'm i love
kind of going down and there's many
people pursuing this path that's the
beauty about this is as many people
helping and seeking and trying to guide
and and
just love interacting with other humans
about hey let's share these experiences
with each other
what can i learn from yours and how can
i share mine that maybe you can draw
upon to help do
more self-reflection have a deeper
conversation just for five minutes
and be able to look in the mirror and
and have the cold hard truths and be
like look dude like you are screwing up
you are not in the place because of you
no one else no one else put you here
except for you
are you okay with that most of us will
say hey you know like
it's hard to have that conversation it's
painful well
most people don't want to take ownership
of that for themselves
they'll want to point the finger and say
it was somebody else's fault or it's
because of this
external circumstance etc but you know i
love
i love the way that you put that it was
beautifully put and it's this amazing
journey
to what i see as somebody grappling with
self-integration like how do i live more
authentically
myself right i have to take these
characters and these personalities
and find a way to weave them into a
greater sense of
not just who i am this story this
identity that i carry with me
but how i channel all of that and then
and then share with the world for the
benefit of other people
and i think finding a way to
create that integration is about
identifying
those values and then bringing your
actions into alignment with them and
that's what
you know creates this this merger you
know that you just so
eloquently articulated yeah
but it's hard man that's it's hard work
i think and
it's hard it's easy for somebody to look
at your story and say oh well this guy's
just been winning his whole life
everything he touches like goes well you
know
that's not the case yeah and and i and i
think
you know it brings it all the way back
to the beginning in this documentary and
understanding that
there's a lot more going on here with
somebody who
is trying to be whether it's somebody
who's trying to be the best in the world
of the olympics
or just an everyday person who's
struggling with you know how to get
through the day
and how to pay the bills and how to feel
a little bit happier
when their head hits the pillow every
night yeah and then
that that's the dream right is that we'd
like to look at other people's lives and
say like they've got this natural
genetic talent
they've got this opportunity or they've
got this gift and that's why it's so
easy
that's why they run this company and the
stock price just shot up or that's why
they
they're so charismatic and what we don't
see is the complexities beneath those
faces that people are wearing during
those times
and human beings are complex and they're
they're emotional
i mean all of us we're just we're so
we're complex individuals and
i just i remember even looking at at
others and sometimes and seeing like man
that guy seems like he has it all and
then like kind of like
like later on laughing and chuckling
myself be like wait wait you don't know
how that guy's life is you have no idea
what's happening in his own head
his between his ears may be the biggest
enemy of all he may actually be the most
tormented
and that's why he's pursuing or having
so much success in the water or doing
this and
you know the documentary i think
highlights that it brings light to show
certainly michael phelps is a is a
perfect example of that
and i think that's why it's so difficult
for people to wrap their heads around
why somebody who's that successful
could possibly harbor you know any kind
of
like mental issue whatsoever and i think
that's why
documentaries like this one are so
important in helping people to
understand
that you guys are human beings that this
is part of the human condition
and that if we want to heal and become
more integrated we have to
have the courage to confront these
problems to
understand that strength comes in that
vulnerability and to give people
permission i think that's the thing that
i took away from it the most like
the permission to raise your hand and
saying i'm having a hard time and i and
i need some help
and that that's okay to do and i think
it begins with
a change in the way that the culture of
sport exists
because the culture of sport doesn't and
has never trained the athletes to
allow that yeah and that then we need
systems set up
to take care of the athletes better you
know to have
programs that are available to not just
the olympic athletes but to every kind
of athlete
whether you're in the nba the nfl or
you're
you know on the junior varsity
volleyball team at your high school
i think that we need mental health
mental health has to be
part of the curriculum and there has to
be
an acceptance that that that
availing yourself of that kind of
service is just part of what it means to
try to be your healthiest the healthiest
version of who you can be
yeah it doesn't matter how many medals
you've won
how much money you have how handsome or
beautiful you are
mental health and the disease of
depression has
no name it will touch anyone and
everyone
and you don't have a choice and that's
what people i think
hopefully will understand from the
documentary is that
the insecurities or the flaws that exist
in all these athletes
is a part of the reason why they rose to
so much success
is there's something missing there that
doesn't fully form this human
but when that competition is over or
when that
that issue has never been addressed
fully that is potentially a very
negative downward spiral and i think
everybody can recognize that
regardless of whether you're an athlete
or not is that because we're human
beings we have a brain and that brain
means that we have emotions and those
feelings and they're real
and we have to recognize and be able to
openly speak about these things and
change the culture of sport in a way
that
still hardens you and still creates
resilience and strength and all these
things that we love about sports
but also has a deeper conversation
around hey
it is okay if you struggle in certain
parts of your life and the
faster and the earlier that we can kind
of head this off at the pass
the better that your life will be when
you retire when you move on and your
potential career
because that balance brings in light it
doesn't have to be this radical seesaw
right where you just cranked on one side
and all this stuff over here in your
personal life has to suffer
you can have this delicate balance and
people have done it
and and hopefully that will be this film
will bring more light and attention
awareness around hey we can do something
about this
and it takes everybody to kind of say
hey i also feel that way
and it's totally cool and that's all
right that's a part of who i am as a
person
and i'm working on it and that person is
two and that person is two and that
person is two and that's how you create
this collective
i think that is happening now not just
in sport but
around around the world yeah i think
that's a good place to end it
thanks for having me i feel good it was
good the the movie's amazing everybody
should definitely check it out
how's your dad doing my dad's amazing
yeah he is still up in seattle he's up
in seattle my dad goes to my dad goes to
work every single day
um seven days a week still hairdresser
still still hairdresser i don't know
who's going to see him does he cut your
hair
he hasn't cut my hair in a while i've
got the i caught the covid 15 inches
my dad's doing very very well uh my dad
yeah we have great conversations
he's still relationship is strong there
stronger than ever
uh my dad is always i think the older he
gets the more philosophical he gets
towards me which is really interesting
so i always ask him a question daddy
coming over for father's day and he
responds back with like this long text
about like the olympic mountains and
like the
the clouds i'm like wait a second wait
is this for me and then i have to like
read deep into the riddle
um all right man well come back and talk
to me again this this is super fun yeah
thank you stay in touch
thanks uh if you want to connect with
apollo
what's the best way instagram um
yeah at apollo ono facebook i'm i'm
across kind of all the channels cool and
when is the book
anticipated to come out depends on when
i finish the last three chapters
come on man this quarantine you got no
excuse
yeah that was when i began this
quarantine i was like oh i'm gonna write
two of these books
right this could be nothing and then uh
i'm hoping by the end of this year i'll
be completely done by the book and then
we'll probably launch by
2021. cool all right man i look forward
to it yeah come back and talk to me when
the book comes out
yeah let's do it cool peace plants
[Music]
you